[Musique]
conservant les traditions des peuples
germaniques les descendants de clovis
considéré le royaume non pas comme un
état et comme un élément du patrimoine
familial que l'on pouvait se partager
entre les différents héritiers mâles
de partage en partage au cours du
sixième siècle marqué par des guerres
fratricides des entités se dessine puis
se consolide
de plus en plus difficiles à concilier
il y a des royaumes et il y a des rois
ils sont un peu la guerre entre eux mais
parfois ils s'entendent bien ils sont à
peu près tous de la même famille
ce sont des francs et ils ont à peu près
les mêmes costumes les mérovingiens vont
régner sur ce qui deviendra l'allemagne
la belgique la france et la suisse du 5e
au 8e siècle les carolingiens doivent
leur nom à charles à charles martel
carolus charles martel qui d'ailleurs le
le grand-père de charlemagne carolus
magnus d'où les carolingiens lesquels
vont régner e sur l'europe de 750 de
l'an 750 jusqu'au 10ème siècle
burgondie neustrie austrasie la france
ne s'appelle pas encore france elle n'a
pas les mêmes limites tout 7,7 france
est en train de naître cette même s'il
vaut mieux parler de francs si souvent
c'est le royaume des francs qui est avec
des bouleversements c'est tout ça est
assez chaotique ya quand même la notion
d'unité des royaumes qui se fait jour
nous nous situons alors au nord d'une
europe occidentale de moins en moins axé
uniquement sur la méditerranée la
logique économique s'oriente vers le
nord avec le bassin parisien comme
relais privilégié neustrie austrasie
deux pays que les rois mérovingiens ont
du mal à réunifier la neustrie est un
territoire du royaume de france met de
la partie nord-ouest du rôle du royaume
de france c'est à dire une grande partie
du royaume la capitale à ce moment là je
crois et et soissons nostry qui va
couvrir également la normandie etc
c'était un territoire assez important
que cette nostri contrairement à
l'australie qui elle était à l'est de la
france qui a d'ailleurs été créé pour le
pour l'un des fils de clovis et dont la
capitale sera reims pendant quelques
temps ce sont des des royaumes avec
des coutumes et des d une origine
commune l'origine franck d'une part et
l'origine gallo romaine des royaumes
assez identique
l'aristocratie en profite pour
s'émanciper c'est peut-être en australie
que s'est construite l'identité la plus
forte
le sentiment d'être ensemble et qu'à
l'extérieur se situe forcément
l'étranger
quand il meurt les aristocrates
australien se font enterrer avec leurs
chevaux ce sont des guerriers deux
d'entre eux arnaud les pépins vont
pourtant le vrai pour la paix en
permettant aux rois mérovingiens de
stries clotaire 2 de prendre le pouvoir
en australie en 613
[Musique]
le mérovingiens les récompenses ont leur
confiant au premier la charge d'évêque
de metz une responsabilité spirituelle
qui ne l'empêchent pas d'avoir un fils
au second échelon une responsabilité
politique de première importance la
mairie du palais d'austrasie arnall de
metz et pépin de landon le fils du
premier épousa la fille du second
[Musique]
de cette union naquit pépin de herstal
père de charles martel et grand-père de
pépin le bref
deux familles les arnulf liens et les
pipis need de familles qui vont s'unir
pour n'en faire qu'une
on dit de cette famille qu'elle est à
l'origine de l'organisation politique de
l'europe telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui
cette famille ce sont les carolingiens
[Musique]
ils tiennent leur nom du plus célèbre
d'entre eux carolus magnus dit
charlemagne
mais leur histoire commence bien plus
tôt
[Musique]
début du 7e siècle un vent nouveau
souffle des îles britanniques
revigorant la spiritualité chrétienne d
- anglo saxons arpente l'occident en
évangélisant et en créant des
communautés
il montre l'exemple de ce que doit être
la vie d'un chrétien colomban et legrand
fondateur monastique du monde
mérovingiens il n'est pas issu du monde
franck puisque c'est en irlande et mais
il est arrivé en burgondie sans doute
dans les années 580 là il fonde un
monastère important luxeuil qui diffuse
des règles dites irlandaise à travers
l'ensemble du monde francs il s'agit en
réalité d'une scierie actualité élitiste
qui s'adresse principalement aux élites
gauloise et qui parle aux aristocrates
épris de saluer surtout de prestige
mais un vent contraire prend forme au
moyen-orient l'archange gabriel par la
mao mais mahomet c'est quelqu'un de plus
spirituel que la plupart de ces de ses
contemporains il est tourné vers l'étude
des religions très jeune on le sait il
est pauvre il a pas beaucoup d'influencé
puis se marie avec une riche veuve qui
lui permet de se consacrer à de la
recherche spirituelle
on peut vraiment appeler ça la recherche
super actuelle et des retraites
il se réfugie dans des grottes solitaire
et il approfondit les écritures
abrahamiques c'était un homme cultivé et
il en vient évidemment au monothéisme
mais il pense que les saintes écritures
on était complètement bafouée et puis il
a sept apparitions de l'ange gabriel qui
lui transmet la version la plus pure des
écritures selon lui et il deviendra très
vite un chef de guerre un chef religieux
les paroles véhiculée par le prophète
remettent en cause l'organisation des
sociétés régies par de fortes traditions
et ses coutumes sont celles des peuples
qui vivent en clans quelle que soit la
région du monde où ces sociétés
s'installe lente et qui hiérarchisent
social dans la logique s'appuie sur les
liens du sang doit s'effacer devant une
communauté de frères unis par une même
foi les musulmans
la mecque est une grande place
commerciale grâce à ces foires dont le
succès est dû au culte des idoles
exposés à l'intérieur d'une structure
parfaitement cubique appelé kaaba c'est
le lieu de nombreux pèlerinages qui
n'ont rien à voir avec les pèlerinages
d'aujourd'hui puisque ce sont des
pèlerinages polythéistes c'est le temps
des idoles c'est le temps de religion
aussi à ses propres à la péninsule
arabique qui sont des religions où on
vénère les signes du ciel tel que les
météorites ce qui est tombé du ciel et
la légende veut que une météorite soit
tombé à la mecque qu'on ait construit
autour un cube de pierre et à partir de
là c'est devenu un lieu saint lieux
saints polythéistes départ et un temple
avec des idoles partout avec des dieux
nombreux et variés mahomet en fera le
premier lieu saint de l'islam vers
lequel les croyants doivent se tourner
pour la prière
il deviendra l'ennemi évidemment de tous
les gens qui vivent des pèlerinages à la
mecque parce que voudra débarrasser le
temple des idoles donc il y a toute
cette période violente qui fait que
mahomet est obligé de devenir chef de
guerre il se réfugie à médine pile
revient à la mecque à la mecque
finalement au bout d'un moment c'est ces
prophéties se finisse pas bien
accueillis puis surtout ça ne change pas
le statut de la mecque même si la mecque
et débarrassée de tous les deux de
toutes les idoles
ça reste un lieu de pèlerinage ça reste
un centre spirituel extrêmement
important et c'est à partir de là que
l'islam mais qu'on appelle parfois
encore comme cela peut naître et après
la mort 2
mais prospérer pendant ce temps là en
occident c'est dans ces palettes ne
strict clotaire ii le mérovingiens
réside en permanence la rivalité entre
industrie et austrasie n'a pas disparu
l'austrasie réclame aussi la présence
d'un roi en 623 dagobert par représenter
son père dans le pays de pépins de
l'antenne nommée à vie mme r du palais
d'austrasie et qu'on peut d'ores et déjà
appeler pépin premier en 627 les saxons
menacèrent la frontière nord du royaume
dagobert nonce à ses troupes à leur
rencontre et pendant la bataille le chef
des saxons parvint à couper la chevelure
du roi mérovingien lord d'un combat
qu'il livre à une armée de saxon en
folie et bien dagobert et reçoit un coup
de deux fléaux sur le casque de la part
d'un an et demi à l'ennemi furieux
qu'ils enlèvent le casque et qu'il
arrache une partie du cuir chevelu et
sur le cuir chevelu une partie de la
coiffure
dagobert et ko pour le compte pendant un
bon moment et puis il réagit et il veut
absolument retrouver pour se venger
retrouver l'auteur de cette blessure de
ce coup violent qu'il l'a
considérablement blessés et leur trou il
va le terrasser val plaqué au sol et il
va le garder comme prisonnier puis va
lui dire et bien dorénavant tu seras mon
coiffeur c'est toi qui entretiendra ma
chevelure
cette anecdote fut peut-être inventé
après son réel les guerriers france
suivent leur chef
parce qu'il porte les cheveux lyon ce
port symbolique de la chevelure longue
et l'assurance de la transmission de
père en fils du mouled la puissance
magique du chef qui lui permet de mener
ses hommes à la victoire
il considère que la force la puissance
le respect est obtenue est acquis grâce
à la chevelure donc ils portent tous une
merveilleuse crinière ce qui permet
d'ailleurs parfois à certains rois qui
veut sommet des petit bâtard à droite et
à gauche de les convoquer ou certains
portant des deux longue crinière de
cheveux disait mais moi je suis un de
vos fils
disons que ne l'est pas est une fausse
et ondres immédiatement la frontière
orientale et maintenant pacifié saxons
turin gien à l'amant et bavarois tout
une germany potentiel plus que jamais
fédérer un royaume dont le centre de
gravité se situe beaucoup plus à l'est
que les cités de nostre
[Musique]
malgré ses succès militaire en australie
dagobert va connaître un exceptionnel
destin posthume
non pour des raisons politiques mais
pour des raisons idéologiques
[Musique]
c'est pour son oeuvre bienfaitrice en
estrie que dagobert rentrer dans
l'histoire
il favorise le développement d'une
abbaye construite autour du culte de
saint denis
saint denis est le premier évêque de
paris il fut décapité par les romains
sur le mont des martyrs en 258
on raconte qu'il prit alors sa tête et
marcha ainsi en direction du nord
saint denis et l'évêque de paris premier
évêque de paris et c'est un chrétien
naturellement qui va à cette époque là
encore connaître la torture des païens
alors torture dramatique parce qu'on va
le flageller mais il va survivre
on va le griller mais il va survivre
tout ça à paris du côté de montmartre
on va lui couper la tête il la ramasse
il l'apprend il traverse la capitale la
fameuse rue des martyrs qui porte encore
ce nom aujourd'hui et il s'en va jusqu'à
saint denis où il dit c'est ici que je
veux faire enterrer c'est autant de
clovis que nous construit une basilique
à l'endroit où il s'est arrêté puis une
abbaye se développe sur ce lieu de
pèlerinage
dagobert donne des terres l'abbaye et
surtout le droit d'organiser des foires
c'est une grande première qu'un roi
accorde ce privilège un centre religieux
en janvier 639 dagobert inaugure une
pratique qui va encore davantage marqué
les esprits il est enseveli dans cette
basilique qui allait devenir la
nécropole de tous ceux qui se
succéderont sur le trône de france
quelques mérovingiens seront enterrés
cet endroit mais à partir de louis 6
tous les rois de france seront enterrés
à s'amener jusqu'à jusqu'à la révolution
évidemment et jusqu'à charles 10 c'est
le début d'une tradition qui sera
dorénavant et pour longtemps utilisée
pour légitimer un pouvoir par les liens
du sang
celui qui domine l'austrasie et pas
l'industrie ne peut être le premier des
francs car cette industrie que se situe
saint denis mais nous n'en sommes pas
encore là
[Musique]
dagobert laisse deux fils clovis 2,5 en
hérite de l'industrie et de la burgondie
sigebert 3 10 ans hérite de l'austrasie
l'austrasie nécessite autant de
précautions et de disponibilité que
d'industriels à burgondie réuni sigebert
ne peut s'appuyer sur pétain premier que
durant une seule année
le premier pipi need meurt en 640
laissant la mairie à son fils grimaud
halde ainsi la mairie du palais
d'austrasie de via d'une charge
héréditaire
[Musique]
à la mort de six verres en 656 il est
alors tentant pour grimaud halde de se
débarrasser du fils du mérovingiens
dagobert 2 alors âgé de quelques années
grimaud al de l'oeuf est on sûr et et
l'envoie dans un monastère irlandais aux
confins de l'occident
limo halde peut maintenant mettre son
fils sur le trône d'austrasie tous deux
sont aussitôt assassiné sur ordre de
clovis 2 après peut-être avoir été
soutenu par ce même clovis afin de se
débarrasser de dagobert 2
c'est dans tous les cas le premier coup
d'état carolingien alors même que cette
dynastie est encore appelée pippin it
les événements qui vont suivre
nous montrerons que les descendants de
grimaud halde retiendront la leçon et
apprendront la prudence
[Musique]
les rois enfante dagobert sont bien en
train de perdre la réalité du pouvoir au
profit des écrans il inaugurait le règne
des rois fainéants entre sensiblement
langue 650 élan 750 apparaissent ce
qu'on appellera les rois fainéants
pourquoi les rois fainéants et bien
parce que ils ne font pas grand chose et
pourquoi ne font-ils pas grand chose
parce que d'abord il règne très
hâtivement très brièvement et les
pouvoirs sont détenus à cette époque-là
par celui qu'on appelle le maire du
palais comme le sras charles martel donc
ce sont ces gens les maires du palais
qui dirigent n'ont rien à faire donc ils
sont oisifs et au 19e siècle sous la
troisième république sous jules ferry eh
bien on va le caricaturer on les imagine
rats dans des lourds chars couverts de
coussin freiné lentement par des boeufs
cheminant de ci de là voilà et ils ont
hérité ce surnom de l'histoire des rois
fainéants était un peu limité
intellectuellement de par la
consanguinité et
et en même temps il était respecté c'est
là on voit apparaître
c'est un des paradoxes de delà de la
période des mérovingiens puisque on voit
apparaître le caractère sacré de la
personne du roi parce que vous savez ces
personnes un peu falote un peu qui avait
l'air un peu stupide été un peu
respectée comme on respecte l'idiot dû
village on se disait mais c'est
peut-être lui qui portent l'avenir
peut-être que le prophète
c'est à ce moment là qu'on voit
apparaître ce qui ce qui après vingt va
nous occuper pendant toute la presse de
l'histoire de france
le caractère sacré de la personne du roi
leurs faiblesses leurs fragilités
michelin explique sa l'historien michel
explique ça très bien et dit que leur
fragilité et a été en même temps leur
force c'est parce que c'était plus des
rois guerriers c'était plus des rois
tout puissant rendant la justice avec
autorité et cetera
c'était des rois mystérieux en fait on
devrait plus que par les deux rois
fainéants
on devrait parler de roy mystérieux
sans véritable autorité il ne faisait
rien ou faisait néant
les rois fainéants rester sur le trône
parce qu'on ne pouvait pas supprimer les
descendants de mérovée comme ceux-ci du
jour au lendemain
puis il restait le trésor royal
manifestation concrète et fétichiste de
la puissance du roi quand un ambassadeur
ou un grand du royaume se présentait aux
mérovingiens
ils étaient conduites au trésor un
mouvement qui se développe depuis le 6e
siècle se poursuivant et se
perfectionnant voie des réseaux se
constituer en créant des liens d'homme à
homme des familles s'unissent par des
alliances s'enrichissent et se paie la
fidélité d'autres chefs de guerre
faisant monter les enchères à un point
que les mérovingiens et puisent leur
trésor royal c'est un contre pouvoir de
plus en plus officielle qui réduit à
néant l'autorité mérovingienne des chefs
de grandes familles rent au nom des
derniers descendants de clovis un contre
pouvoir formée par des familles parfois
rivales ce qui retarde l'échéance
des 687 le réseau des pipis need
permettent à pépin de herstal de réunir
entre ses mains les mairies d'austrasie
et de neustrie dont les transmissions
deviennent terry d'iter
pépin deux étapes les princeps c'est à
dire qu'ils les princes des francs la
famille de pépin 2 s'est enrichie
pendant que les rois se ruinaient c'est
de ce transfert du trésor royal que la
dynastie mérovingienne meurt à le trésor
royal
il y à il ya eu dans toute cette période
on est toujours dans ce passage de la la
gaule romana la gaule franck et période
de très grands désordres et il ya toutes
sortes de légendes notamment dit qu'il
n'y avait pas de
séparation entre la fortune privée et la
fortune du royaume sans cesse être
utilisé à la défense de l'intérêt
général
en réalité très vite il y a eu une
séparation entre les comptabilités privé
les comptabilités publiques comme on
dirait de nos jours et il y a eu un
trésor royal qui était qui faisait
partie de la de l'image et de l'autorité
du roi notamment dans la période de
maire du palais parce que et maire du
palais il avait autorité sur le trésor
royal la base de la vitalité économique
en europe occidentale est alors
l'influencent grandissante des grands
domaines agricoles contrôlée par
l'aristocratie mais aussi et de plus en
plus par l'église
la france est un pays le restera elle
restait toujours est un pays qui a des
dimanches domaine agricole qui ont été
mis en valeur pendant la période gallo
romaine
ce qui est à la fois je me faiblesse
parce que ce sont des c'est une partie
vulnérable du territoire ce sont des
espaces difficile à préserver ces
espaces agricoles la paysannerie sais
pas c'est ça se défend plus
difficilement que les déserts les
préjudices sont nombreux dans les
invasions dans les guerres on peut
mettre le feu à des champs de blé on
peut détruire des greniers c'est mais en
même temps c'est une force
extraordinaire c'est ce qui permet à la
gaule gallo romaine de conquérir ces
conquérants c'est à dire que les francky
mais le même des tribus extrêmement
nombreuse des populations venues de
partout mais les les francs deviendront
très vite des gallo-romains pourquoi
parce que pourrait dire de façon très
prosaïque il y a à manger en france
pépin 2 peut s'appuyer tout comme les
rois sur des sommes des guerriers qui
lui ont juré fidélité par un serment
d'allégeance en échange est pas le roc 3
des terres mais ce n'est plus une part
du butin
c'est un bénéfice on voit apparaître des
hommes de rien des hommes de peu qu'ils
sont nommés seigneur te dire on leur
donne un fief
parce que le fief est vacant parce qu'il
n'ya pas quelqu'un qui se distinguent
particulièrement comme seigneur ou parce
qu'il ya eu un mariage ou parce que ou
parce qu'il faut distinguer quelqu'un
qui est né qu'au départ qu'un simple
guerrier ou un simple paysan mais on en
fait un seigneur
les guerriers sont liés à jamais à
peypin 2 dans ce système pyramidal tout
autant économique que politique en
s'appuyant sur une conception
radicalement verticale du pouvoir des
pins de règne sur le royaume des francs
seul l'aquitaine reste une principauté
autonome
mais plus que ce pouvoir politique et
économique
c'est la rencontre de pépins de avec le
moine vue libre horde en 690 qui va
définir les nouveaux rapports de
puissance durant les siècles à venir
willebrord est un moine anglo saxons qui
comme bon nombre de ses compatriotes qui
ont confié leur vie au christ prêche
l'évangile chez les peuples encore
paillat à l'est du royaume de pépin 2
or le pipe in it vient de soumettre les
frisons il propose alors à willy brand
ordre de prendre en main
l'évangélisation de la région
dans les années 690 la grande famille
des pipis need soutien des missionnaires
notamment des missionnaires actifs en
frise dans la région des bouches du rhin
ces missionnaires sont pour la plupart
des anglo saxons le plus célèbre vili
brand contribuer à la conversion des
frisons et obtient des terres autour du
domaine des sternes art dans l'actuelle
royaume du luxembourg ce n'est pas tant
cette proposition qui rend la rencontre
historique mais le fait que pépin
s'assure de la bénédiction du pape pour
officialiser la mission qu'il confie à
willibrord dhr c'est le premier
rapprochement de la famille de pépins
avec rome
l'une comme l'autre les deux puissances
qui sont sur le point de se constituer
vont maintenant se trouver des intérêts
communs en recherche toutes les traces
de la paix romaine
c'est à dire que le l'église est associé
à une oeuvre de paix même si elle
préconise de façon très violente la
guerre contre les ennemis de cette paix
mais il ya toujours cette idée que l'on
va retrouver par le soutien de l'église
romane par le soutien des papes
on va retrouver quelque chose de l'unité
romaine plus que le pouvoir politique et
économique le pouvoir spirituel est
indispensable à celui qui veut régner
tout d'abord parce que le pouvoir
spirituel s'appuient de plus en plus sur
le pouvoir économique
le succès des foires de saint-denis
transforme la petite communauté en eau
puissant monastère ceci quelques
décennies après la mort de dagobert
premier leur bienfaiteur
c'est la seule abbaye qui a le privilège
d'organiser des foires mais ce n'est pas
la seule à recevoir des donations de
grands soucieux du repos de leurs âmes
la famille de pépin a pu profiter de son
capital foncier pour fonder bon nombre
d' abbey
[Musique]
ensuite le pouvoir spirituel détient
potentiellement le pouvoir culturel
potentiellement ans seulement
pour l'heure le régionalisme domine
encore face au centralisme que tentent
d'organiser pépins mais c'est une
transition fondamentale qui est en train
de s'opérer
bientôt le réseau des fidèles guerrier
et le réseau des abbayes favoriseront
l'émergence d'une autorité centrale qui
gommera les particularismes régionaux à
l'intérieur d'un état tout autant
puissance idéologique que puissance
politique une puissance soutenue par
rome
[Musique]
il est difficile de connaître la
politique extérieure des dirigeants de
ce monde là les chroniqueurs de l'époque
s'intéressent davantage à une querelle
entre voisins à cause en juger aux
politiques autour de la méditerranée le
centre de gravité de ce monde se déplace
de la méditerranée vers la mer du nord
et le commerce avec l'angleterre
c'est d'ailleurs de l'espace
méditerranéen d'une menace va fédérer
encore davantage ces populations
d'europe occidentale autour d'une
identité commune en 711 après l'afrique
du nord
c'est l'espagne wisigothique qui est
envahis par les musulmans arabes et
berbères la péninsule ibérique devient
al andalus en 714 c'est aussi en 714
qu'hummer pépin de herstal
son héritage est encore fragile
les aristocrates ne strien détruisent
leurs réseaux de famille mis en place
par le puissant australien une famille
d'austrian s'empare de la mer et du
palais et utilise un prince mérovingiens
pour en faire un roi
à la mort du patriarche cesson bâtard
charles qui calme les velléités de ceux
qui doutent de la puissante organisation
qui est en train de se mettre en marche
pépin avait pu donner à ce bâtard ah non
jamais encore porté chez les pipis need
carle ou charles
c'est ce nom que choisir à la postérité
pour désigner la dynastie issus de pépin
les carolingiens sur l'oeuvre de ce
premier charles est considérable mais
celle de son petit fils à qui l'on
donnera le même nom a encore davantage
marqué les esprits voici donc l'histoire
de charles martel
le grand-père de charlemagne charles a
déjà 30 ans en 714 c'est un homme
politique aguerri
il réussit à repousser l'avancée des
nostri en australie mais il a besoin
d'argent et d'un roi
maire du palais d'austrasie il fait
proclamer roi un autre prince
mérovingiens clotaire 4 et se prépare à
donner la riposte industrias
ceux-ci s'allie avec les aquitains
accompagné des redoutables guerriers
basque
le charles donne un premier exemple de
sa maîtrise de l'art de la guerre en lan
et 720 il fait mieux que mettre en
déroute aquitains et basques il se rend
maître du palais de neustrie il récupère
au passage le roi mérovingien d2 strien
chilpéric 2 le sien ayant rendu l'âme
à la tête de deux royaumes charles est
appelée princeps comme son père le pape
va même jusqu'à l'appeler vice roi comme
son père charles favorise l'expansion et
la cohésion de la chrétienté en
protégeant les missionnaires
dans ce monde encore empreint de
romanité commencent à se superposer aux
structures issues de lempire des
structures nouvelles
des nouveaux liens se tissent le chaos
et l'insécurité pousse des hommes à
s'unir à d'autres les uns cherchent en
protection et honneur les autres
puissance et gloire les uns deviennent
les vassaux des autres des seigneurs
tenté ou obligés de prendre des
initiatives en l'absence d'une autorité
centrale reconnue
on voit apparaître des des seigneurs qui
sont en base qui sont les seigneurs bien
ce sont les plus forts 1 ce sont les
ceux qui protègent ils sont assez forts
ils sont assez organisés ils sont forts
physiquement sont des chefs de guerre et
puis son fort intellectuellement
puisqu'ils savent administrés construire
un château par exemple ce qui est une
grande protection pour les gens ils
savent protégés c'est à partir de de
cette période de grand trouble qui qui
est qui précède les carolingiens mais
qui va accompagner toute la période
carolingienne que le voit vraiment
apparaître la notion de fiefs notion de
vassal la notion de souveraineté
charles poursuit la politique de son
père en organisant les deux royaumes à
l'aide d'un réseau d'amis et de
familiers un réseau qui densifie et
qu'il veut pérenne
il va alors utiliser à merveille la
nouvelle logique féodal définissant les
rapports entre guerriers est en passe de
devenir un des fondements de la société
médiévale occidental le plus bas de
l'échelle sociale juin refuse corroy
c'est toujours la même notion c'est je
te protège et en échange tu me sers tu
me sers et ça va très loin servir ça
veut dire tu fais la guerre si je te
demande de faire la guerre est humeur
pour moi et partir des petits seigneurs
qui rendent hommage à de plus grands
seigneurs et ainsi de suite jusqu'au roi
eh bien on arrive un système pas
pyramidale qui va qui va prospérer sous
charlemagne mais qui en fait exister un
peu avant
ces guerriers sont encore pour la
plupart des fantassins armé d'une hache
d'une lance d'une épée longue d'une épée
courte d'un casque conique et d'un
bouclier de bois un petit nombre d'entre
eux montent à cheval
le guerrier à cheval est plus efficace
qu'un fantassins mais le cheval coûte le
prix de 20 vaches une innovation
technique va apporter une efficacité
encore plus redoutable au guerrier à
cheval et va justifier par cette
plus-value les investissements que son
l'achat d'un cheval et son entretien des
cavaliers nomades
originaire des steppes de mongolie et
s'étant installés le long du danube à
porte a vécu un équipement qui permet
aux guerriers à cheval d'avoir les deux
mains libres à l'apparition de l'étrier
dans l'armée franck marque le début d'un
processus qui fera de la cavalerie la
base de tous les succès militaires en
europe occidentale jusqu'à la guerre de
cent ans les trier qui jusque là n'était
connue que par les peuples de la step se
diffuse à travers l'occident l'étrier
permet désormais aux cavaliers de
charger avec la lance coucher et de
mener ainsi des attaques dévastatrices
contre les armées de fantassins à partir
de la fin du 7e siècle la cavalerie
devient la reine des batailles
alors que jusque là elle ne servait que
de force annexes cela conduit à une
militarisation net de l'armée qui
désormais plus une armée de masse comme
à l'époque de clovis
mais de plus en plus une armée de
spécialistes des gens très riches
principalement des vassaux c'est aussi
la mort ce d'une adaptation du système
qui régit les liens d'homme à homme
charles octroie des terres et équipe ses
guerriers en chevaux l'investissement
est telle que la cérémonie qui voit le
guerrier jury fidélité n'est plus
seulement officielle comme autant de
pépins 2 elle est solennel le sermon
devient un rituel de plus en plus ça
crée le lien les droits et les devoirs
sont de plus en plus précisément défini
les serments de fidélité des guerriers à
leurs supérieurs sont connus depuis le
5ème siècle c'est une création romaine
toutefois les barbares ont adopté ces
serments qui prennent des noms variable
on parle de truste au début de l'époque
mérovingienne
nous on parlera plutôt de vasselage à
partir du viiie siècle
le système se codifie mais manque encore
ce code de l'honneur qui fera de ces
guerriers à cheval les héros des romans
de chevalerie mais aussi les acteurs des
grandes batailles de l'histoire
médiévale pour l'heure charles doit
davantage compter sur des fantassins
dont les épaisse chemise de cuir se
recouvrent de plaques de métal et c'est
effectivement d'une muraille de fer dont
un besoin charles quand le duc
d'aquitaine fait appel à lui pour
stopper la progression des cavaliers
musulmans les troupes de l'émir d'al
andalus déjà maître de toute la
péninsule ibérique lancent des raids qui
les emmènent chaque fois plus loin en
aquitaine et même jusqu'au royaume des
francs
les mahométans comme on disait à
l'époque le terme musulmans ou islam ce
sont des termes qui sont venus beaucoup
plus tard et dans l'occident médiéval
d'employés pas ce terme on a plutôt
employer un terme qui venait du grec aux
origines mystérieuses de l'est on disait
les sarrasins acheter les musulmans et
donc il y avait dans cette invasion de
l'espagne un ralliement à la pensée
religieuse de mahomet tu dit des tribus
ibères
qui ont été extrêmement sensible à la
pénétration des conquérants venus
d'arabie et qui ont fait donner une
force considérable aux armées qui sont
remontés vers la gaule franck en 732
après avoir pillé la basilique sainte
hilaire de poitiers l'armée arabe et sur
la route du monastère le plus populaire
du royaume des francs
saint martin de tours les motivations
sont plus matériel que spirituel les
abbayes chrétiennes sont richement doté
il y a dans cette invasion une invasion
comme il y en a eu beaucoup d'autres
mais il ya quelque chose de plus via une
revendication spirituel stérile faut les
gens qui sont cons qui changent de
religion
il adopte les préceptes de mahomet c'est
à ce moment là que healy a prise de
conscience d'un péril de la chrétienté
donc l'église latine met tout son poids
dans la balance et une mobilisation
énorme
des royaumes francs et l'homme qui
symbolise tout ça c'est le maire du
palais charles martel c'est donc sur la
voie romaine entre poitiers et tours
qu'après sept jours d'escarmouches et
d'observation entre les deux armées 25
octobre 732 un affrontement inédit voit
les cavaliers de l'émir se heurter à la
discipline de fer des guerriers du
prince des francs des guerriers soudés
par des liens d'homme à homme et qui
défendent leur territoire
la bataille est violente les troupes
musulmanes en razzia depuis des mois
sont écrasés on pense que ça a été une
guerre extrêmement meurtrière et avec de
très grands pillage de part et d'autre
part il faut pas voir ça comme une
guerre entre civilisé et barbare les
musulmans venus d'espagne était assez
raffiné
ça n'empêchait pas d'être des grands
combattants
et puis
les héritiers des francs qui étaient là
étaient aussi de solides gaillards donc
ça a été une empoignade extrêmement dur
les conséquences à court terme de ce
triomphe sont de l'ordre de la politique
intérieure
l'aquitaine est assujettie au royaume
des francs c'est alors la principale
ambition de charles sur le plan
religieux l'islam est alors considéré
par les chrétiens comme une hérésie
parmi d'autres il est par contre
possible que sur le plan culturel
charles et ses contemporains et eu
conscience d'un choc des civilisations
[Musique]
les conséquences à moyen terme seront
bientôt évoqué avec la gestion de
l'héritage de charles par son fils pépin
le bref la bataille de poitiers est un
message de dieu en 737 à la mort de son
roi mérovingien thierry 4 charles ne le
remplace pas par un autre il a assez
d'autorité et de prestige pour se passer
des descendants de mérovée mais il ne va
pas jusqu'à se couronner lui même les
conséquences à long terme sont celles
que la mémoire populaire a bien sûr
retenez cela commence au 9e siècle avec
le surnom de martel donné à charles en
référence un héros guerrier de l'ancien
testament lui aussi capable d'asséner à
ses ennemis des coûts d'une telle
violence qu'il ne pouvait être que
soutenu et béni par dieu
les oeuvres traduisant l'imaginaire
populaire nous montre le roi charles
dressées sur les étriers qui saigne sa
monture soulevant son arme au dessus de
sa tête tel un marteau s'apprêtant à
frapper l'infidèle charles martel
devient le défenseur de la chrétienté
est le garant de la civilisation ou
plutôt d'une civilisation celle de
l'occident
celle de l'europe il devient par la même
occasion le premier chevalier charles
martel ne fut jamais roi de france
mais quand il décède en 741 il est
inhumé dans l'abbatiale de saint denis
la basilique n'est pas encore la
nécropole des rois de france
mais l'histoire finit donc pardonné à
charles une sépulture digne de lui
ami des moines de l'abbaye de
saint-denis charles martel leur a confié
l'éducation de son fils pépin le bref
des pins tient son surnom de sa petite
taille mais dans le bref va épouser
berthe aux grands pieds et ils vont
avoir un fils charlemagne et on sait que
charlemagne grâce à un tibia que l'on a
pu étudier scientifiquement que l'on a
retrouvé avec sa chapelle dans sa
sépulture
on voit ce que charlemagne pouvait
mesurer quelque chose comme 1 m 85 1 m
ce qui est étonnant d'ailleurs puisque
son père était censé être tout petit
petit petit puisque son surnom pépin le
bref indique que c'était un tout petit
bonhomme il devient tout naturellement à
la mort de son père
le maire du palais de neustrie car tout
naturellement son frère aîné car le mans
hérite de la mairie du palais
d'austrasie la mort du patriarche à la
poigne de fer réveille les ambitions
d'autres familles aristocratiques et
même celle des mérovingiens
elle réveille également les velléités
d'indépendance des peuples située sur la
frontière orientale
[Musique]
en 743 deux ans après la mort de charles
car le mans et pépins sont contraints de
trouver un mérovingiens à mettre sur le
trône
le temps n'est pas venu pour s'attribuer
la couronne il convient de réformer
profondément les mentalités et donc
l'église afin d'en finir définitivement
avec les relents de paganisme et toutes
les superstitions fétichiste notamment
celles qu'un roi doit porter la
chevelure longue il faut aussi concilier
tous les particularismes traditionnel à
régionaux si on veut une entité qu'on
puisse gouverner c'est car le mans qui
montre la voie à prendre
réunissant un concile des autorités
ecclésiastiques d'austrasie dont les
conclusions devront recevoir la
bénédiction du pape
pépin le bref fait de même en hausse
très on impose aux membres du clergé
une discipline plus stricte ils doivent
donner l'exemple afin que l'ensemble des
peuples à l'intérieur du royaume des
francs ader tôt même idéal et surtout
respecte un mode de vie ainsi que les
lois qui permettent d'atteindre cet
idéal cet idéal c'est de salut éternel
le but est bien de créer une communauté
unis par une même foi cette moralisation
de la société est pris à coeur par
carloman à tel point qu'en 747
il renonce au pouvoir et aux choses de
ce monde il prend l'habit et se retire
dans l'abbaye du mont cassin en italie
que car le mans ait pris cette décision
spontanément ou plus ou moins contraints
par des complots qui planent toujours
sur ceux qui exercent le pouvoir
cela fait les affaires de pépin le bref
qui a le champ libre pour réaliser son
grand projet après avoir préparé le
terrain sur le plan idéologique reste à
mener une campagne de propagande sur le
plan politique juridique et même
institutionnels
on est quand même toujours dans la
monarchie élective ont choisi ont choisi
celui qui va être roi et ça reste même
si après ça devient un simulacre ça
restera toujours dans le dans les
fondements de la monarchie française
on aura toujours un simulacre d'élection
même au moment du sacre d'henri iv il y
a un semblant d'élection pour qui est
inquiète un rappel du fait que le roi
ait choisi par les seigneurs même si
souvent après s'est imposée s'est
imposée par l'hérédité s'est imposée par
la force imposée par le pouvoir en place
mais il ya toujours cette notion
élective dans la monarchie qui doit être
roi celui qui règne
effectivement et qui en a les
compétences ou celui qui a les cheveux
longs et qui s'est à peine monté à
cheval
que vaut ce roi si on le compare aux
fils de charles martel la bataille de
poitiers n'était pas un message divin
pépin le bref confie la responsabilité
de cette opération de communication aux
moines de l'abbaye de saint-denis
l'anecdote de dagobert dont la chevelure
aurait été coupé par le chef des saxons
et peut-être élaboré à cette époque plus
méthodiquement texte de référence à
l'appui les moines apporte la preuve que
la destitution d'un roi faisant néant et
donc incompétents ne serait pas une
première
il est cependant indispensable d'avoir
l'appui d'une autorité théoriquement
impartiale et qui soit en même temps une
référence dans le domaine spirituel pour
pouvoir envisager le passage à l'acte en
751 avec l'aval du pape
pépin le bref et couper la longue
chevelure du dernier descendant de
mérovée childéric 3 qui ne devait pas
être à une humiliation près les
mérovingiens étant dans une phase de
perte de puissance depuis le début du
viiie siècle et par le bref considère
dans les années 740 qu'il est temps
désormais de changer la dynastie royale
il envoie une lettre au pape pour
obtenir l'autorisation de déposer le
dernier mérovingiens la réponse lui
parvient l'autorisant âge éliminer ce
mérovingiens le dernier héritier de
clovis fini ses jours dans un monastère
acclamé par les guerriers les évêques et
les grandes familles pépin le bref est
couronné roi des francs dans l'abbatiale
de saint médard de 60
c'est un coup d'état l'expression
paraître anachronique c'est surtout le
terme d'état qui ne semble pas adaptée à
la réalité politique
mais c'est bien cela que sont en train
d'organiser les carolingiens non
seulement un état mais plus encore
une véritable puissance idéologique
il faut installer l'idée que le roi est
un seigneur au dessus des seigneurs qui
l'a certain héritage un peu plus sacré
que les autres etc mais qu' il est aussi
le plus fort le plus le plus habile le
plus intelligent et donc
pépin et ses successeurs de l'épée ping
feront tout pour que le la valeur de
l'individu dépasse les liens du sang
pépin le bref ne se contente pas d'être
couronné il se fait sacrer roi comme les
rois de l'ancien testament jamais ça
mérovingiens n'a été sacrée comme clovis
ils ont été baptisés puis couronné il
tenait leur légitimité de dieu mes
pépins fait mieux il est l'élu il ne se
contente pas d'être en accord avec le
projet divin il est censé le concrétiser
l'assentiment de rome a été obtenue par
ce que le pape est en danger
les lombards qui occupent le nord de la
péninsule italienne depuis 568 menace
les domaines qui permettent à la papauté
d'être indépendante économiquement et
donc politiquement
rome a besoin d'un allié en occident et
les relations avec la famille de pépin
le bref sont basées sur une réelle
complicité depuis maintenant deux
générations
départ le bref comme tous ses
prédécesseurs à d'excellents contacts
avec le siège apostolique il écrit
régulièrement au pape il soutient les
missionnaires que le pape envoient en
occident grâce à ses contacts
excellent avec rome et peint obtient une
aura de monarque chrétiens avant même de
recevoir la couronne de roi
la menace l'embardée bientôt tels que
trois ans après le couronnement de pépin
le bref en 754 c'est le pape lui même
qui se déplace en territoire franc et
dom officiellement le roi carolingien
protecteur des romains
pépin en profite pour donner plus de
crédit à sa nouvelle couronne en se
faisant ça crée une deuxième fois par le
pape dans l'abbatiale de saint denis
et cette fois c'est toute une famille
qui est sacré les deux fils de pépin car
le mans et charles reçoivent également
l'onction papale c'est l'acte de
naissance d'une dynastie qui amène un
charles jusqu'au couronnement impérial
mais c'est bien son père qui assure non
seulement la transition entre les rois
de la première race et ceux de la
seconde mais aussi une transition
institutionnelle la moralisation de la
société s'accompagne d'une modernisation
du droit et va de pair avec la
centralisation du pouvoir
le projet est bien de gouverner une
communauté unis par une même foi à
partir d'un point central tout autant
paul idéologique et politique que pôle
économique vers ce point central
convergent les ressources économiques
le trésor royal de patrimoine privé
devient budget d'état ce point central
n'est pas encore paris même si saint
denis et déjà éminemment stratégique
pépins comme les mérovingiens n'a pas de
résidence fixe et la capitale de
charlemagne sera aix la chapelle en
effet les carolingiens c'est plus que la
france
si l'allemagne est bientôt l'italie la
mutation que cette famille a opéré est à
l'origine de l'organisation politique de
l'europe une même foi sous l'autorité de
rome une même logique de fonctionnement
tant culturel et social que juridique et
administrative pour des peuples d'une
grande diversité
[Musique]
se sentant malades pépin le bref ce fait
transporter à saint denis le 23
septembre 768
ils sacrifient à la coutume franck en
divisant son royaume
entre ses deux fils il meurt le
lendemain à 54 ans
quand les descendants de pépins et de
charlemagne tiendront moins solidement
que des rênes du pouvoir il se
raccrocheront au wagon mérovingiens pour
légitimer leur pouvoir contester bien
sûr la locomotive clovis pouvait être
tentante mais la proximité et le
souvenir de dagobert rendait les choses
encore plus vraisemblable et puis si
saint denis devient une puissance
politique et un centre d'élaboration
idéologique c'est aussi grâce à dagobert
defosse généalogie fleurir alors au 9e
siècle on inventa des filles attaquent
aubert afin qu'elle puisse épouser des
pipis need quand les carolingiens
finiront par céder la place des quatre
coins de l'europe
d'autres familles grefferont des
ramifications dans leur arbre
généalogique afin de se rattacher à la
matrice carolingienne une matrice défini
par l'association de deux pouvoirs le
pouvoir politique et le pouvoir
spirituel